below the Medway viaduct in Kent Nettles
have reclaimed a shrine left in the
memory of azra Kamal
a 21 year old died here in July 2020
falling from the Dual carriageway Bridge
after her car broke down and caught fire
she was traveling back to London with a
male friend
paramedics had tried in vain to save
azra police were called to the scene but
azra's family were recently shocked to
discover what the police had tweeted in
the immediate wake of that investigation
Kent crime scene investigators
congratulate themselves on the speed of
their work using a gif from the movie
Top Gun characters Maverick and Goose
high five the words great teamwork as
they celebrate identifying the deceased
person within 90 minutes of being at the
scene
this is azra's Mother Nevers
that tweet was just horrendous I could
not really could not believe that
professional police officers would
high-five themselves and Pat themselves
on the back on the back of my daughter's
demise it's more than insensitive it's
unacceptable that they think that they
can still the forensic team in Kent
think that that's acceptable what is the
mindset of people investigating crimes
on our behalf what is their mindset
another tweet celebrates the police
drone work with the hashtag cracking bit
of Kit and another reports within hours
that the police are satisfied there are
no suspicious circumstances even though
Ezra's mother is being told they're
still investigating
the initial suspect the man azra was
traveling with said that in the darkness
azra had not seen the drop as she
climbed over the central reservation
barrier he was released and the
investigation closed before the end of
the first day
strikes me that a murder investigation
being open and closed within 24 hours
not an adequate investigation I think
it's shocking that with an investigation
ongoing and in fact within a few hours
of of Never as having been informed of
her daughter's death the police would
brag about the expediency of the
investigation or the impressiveness of
their kid
police could have conducted what's
called a forensic post-mortem to look
for Clues as to whether anything
physical had happened to azra before she
fell but they instead did a standard
postmortem deciding that what happened
here was not suspicious
an independent review of azra's Case by
Essex police suggested a forensic level
postmortem would have helped avoid
unanswered questions by being able to
negate any third-party involvement and
that it may have been prudent to release
the suspect under investigation rather
than close the case
do the job that you're supposed to do
look at the information look at the
leads
look at the timelines look at the
interviews go back to the witnesses yeah
because no one saw azra die
in quest into Ezra's death returned a
verdict of misadventure Kent Police says
their investigation was full and
thorough and officers determined there
were no suspicious circumstances the
investigation by Essex police concluded
the service provided by Kent Police had
been acceptable
the independent office for police
conduct made the same conclusion
although that decision was appealed and
has been reopened the Tweet has been
removed and the complaint is being
reviewed by an independent police force
the family think this image reflects the
way things were investigated Jason
Farrell Sky News